the top stories from Sky News live in
the city ministers draw up contingency
plans for the collapse of Britain's
biggest water company Thames water
We'll Be Live at the European Central
Bank Forum in Portugal amid warnings
that interest rates are going to
continue to rise
worryingly slow a new report accuses the
government of missing key opportunities
to make progress on Net Zero
plus why the UK's multi-billion pound
Veterinary Market is moving towards
subscription-based services
foreign
good morning to you you're watching Ian
King live with me Emma Crosby an hour of
business and economic news from the
Heart of the City for you now the
government is reportedly drawing up
contingency plans for the collapse of
Thames water it comes as a reportedly
growing doubt in Whitehall about the
ability of Britain's biggest water
company to service its 14 billion pound
debt pile while Sky News has learned
that ministers are holding discussions
right now about the possibility of
placing Thames water into a special
Administration regime that would
effectively take the company into
temporary public ownership Let's cross
over now to our business correspondent
Paul Kelso who's got the very latest for
us Paul and we are actually hearing from
the UK government aren't we
reassuring people on the financial
situation of Thames water what more have
you heard
um so let's start with the background to
this which is Thames water is the UK's
biggest uh water provider one in four
people rely on it but it has a mountain
of debt 14 billion pounds of debt around
10 percent of which uh becomes due at
the end of this year a bond matures at
that that's one of the reasons why the
company has been attempting we
understand to raise around a billion
pounds from its shareholders which
include a couple of very big pension
companies one in Canada one here the
university uh pensions fund looks after
lecturers and the like as well as a
couple of sovereign wealth funds Abu
Dhabi and China uh that may explain why
yesterday afternoon completely
unexpectedly its chief executive Sarah
Bentley resigned she was well into a
turnaround plan she she called it she'd
been talking about it publicly just a
couple of weeks ago did not feel like a
planned uh departure she's faced a lot
of pressure over the size of her
remuneration so she wouldn't take a
bonus but she was taking reportedly
massive pay packet north of 1.5 million
pounds huge public disquiet particularly
over the issue of sewage discharges now
we understand the government is
concerned less about what's been pumped
into the rivers than the money that may
or may not be in terms is control so
discussions contingency plans at an
early stage we understand around a
special Administration as it's called
you'll remember that bulb the big energy
provider was put into special
Administration rather than allowing it
to collapse what does the special
Administration allow it allows the
government effectively to underwrite the
company to keep it going to ensure that
service remains provided to customers
water coming into homes and sewage going
out in the other direction
without interruption while a buyer is
found on the rescue packages put
together and we've had a statement from
the government this morning a government
spokesman I'm afraid I can't see all of
it but it says that this is effectively
a matter for the company and its
shareholders so a response initially it
would appear and I would like to bring
you more of it uh it would appear the
initial response is that this is a
matter for terms but of course it's a
huge issue for the government and a huge
issue for the water regulator off what
and they have been in number 11 or
certainly somewhere meeting the chance
of the exchecker Jeremy Hunt this
morning this meeting was called with off
what the water regulator off com the
communications regulator governs
broadband and the like Communications
and off gem which is we are familiar
looks after the energy Market as well as
the financial conduct Authority in the
competition of markets Authority all of
them are The Regulators of stencil to be
the reason for it was the cost of living
the chancellor looking to remind them
perhaps for public appearance as much
for internal Communications as anything
to ensure that companies as prices begin
to fall uh they are those price Falls as
inflation needies are passed on to
customers uh off what it's a timely
meeting that the regulator should be in
there given the attention really very
squarely on the Water Industries morning
and therein lies the challenge of a
privatized water industry we want to
deliver value to customers and keep
bills down down and allow companies to
take a profit from a market which in
fact there isn't a great deal of
competition you can't choose supervise
your water well ultimately you're going
to face a question about how much can be
invested to improve infrastructure
particularly around sewage and that's
the challenge that's why so many water
all the water companies have such
enormous amounts of debt Thames water
has got a flood of it question is
whether the company will go under
okay Paul for now thank you very much
just restrate what Paul was saying are
you a government spokesperson just uh
confirming the last few minutes saying
that the sector as a whole is
financially resilient and that off what
that's the governing body uh looking
after of course the water companies in
this country says it continues to
monitor the financial position of all
the Key Water and Wastewater companies
of course we'll watch situations
surrounding Thames water and bring you
any developing news on that as and when
we get it here on Sky News let's have a
look at some other stories making the
headlines now boots is going to close
300 stores across the UK over the next
12 months that's despite strong sales
and growth it's in response to an
increase in traffic to the chains
website there'll be no redundancies and
staff will be offered work at nearby
stores
members of the PCS Union working at the
British museum are to go on strike next
month they're due to walk out for six
days between the 11th and the 16th of
July the action is part of its national
campaign over pay pensions and job
security and redundancy terms which
began in November of last year
now the government has been accused of
missing key opportunities to reach Net
Zero in the latest progress report by
the climate change committee it
highlights four areas in particular
where there hasn't been enough progress
that's industry transport buildings and
also fuel supply
well I think politicians feel they're
doing a little and want to do something
but I think the key thing for us is that
they're not doing enough so the
Strategic decisions that the country
needs to take on things like the
transport system how we heat our homes
we just heard from that report there
really important issues they're happier
to duck those issues and leave them till
after the next general election I think
that's not going to work so what we're
saying today is you've got to make those
decisions early and help the country on
this the school for Net Zero by 2015.
I'm joined Now by Angela needle she is
director of strategy at caded gas and
she's also campaign director at hello
hydrogen Angela great to have you on the
program this morning I think Greenpeace
have said there is almost no progress in
this progress report and how concerned
are you that the UK government's likely
to miss its targets for 2030.
I mean I think we should all be really
concerned and we mustn't forget that
what's coming to reality is that getting
to Net Zero is a colossal change
um for all of us
um at the energy sector moving away from
natural gas Shifting The Way We heat our
homes and drive vehicles and we mustn't
underestimate that we've got to bring
people with us on this journey and so
whilst government have made great
strides in putting some policies in
place
um the CCC report is pretty clear that
more needs to be done to get us there a
little bit quicker than we are doing
right now Chris Stark the the chief
executive of the CCC was on a k Burley
show just a few minutes ago he says that
government needs to put policy into
place now and you're just not seeing
government action would you agree with
that
well I'll give you a good example here
so in the hydrogen sector and we know
that about 30 of the Future Energy
System needs to be hydrogen
um and yet we are waiting for business
models that support bringing investment
into the UK and we're being told we need
to wait a couple more years before
before that's in place and we've got
projects today like high net which is a
massive industrial cluster project in
the Northwest where hydrogen will fuel
businesses in that region to stay in the
UK were waiting for funding or certainty
if you like the business models that
enables our investors to invest so it's
really important and it's not just I
mean these projects are huge scale and I
would agree that there is significant
amounts of infrastructure there is no
regrets like pipelines like storage
light Renewables that need to be
delivered regardless of which pathway we
choose to get to Net Zero
so what will you talk to the government
what happens I mean can you give us a
sense of the conversations you're having
right now is there pushback or are they
just too busy doing other things for
example trying to sort the economy out
well I mean there is no doubt that
there's lots of things going on in
government you know through brexit
um energy crisis that war in Ukraine
there's definitely
um dividing if you like old needs for
funding
um but if we are going to get to Net
Zero and the few things that we do need
to do collectively Industries ready to
help you know we uh we should work more
collaboratively things are seen in in
silos a little bit and I would like us
to be more joined up between electricity
and gas and policies are being put in
place but you know I I worry as well
that a change in government and the
energy bill that is seems to be taking a
long time to get through things just all
seem to be pushed down the line and if
anything we need them to be brought
forward rather than delayed
I mean the reality is that every single
home in the UK will need to change its
heating at some point won't it and we
spoke to someone on Sky News earlier I
think it cost six thousand pounds to put
a heat pump in I mean in the middle of a
cost of a living crisis it's just not
affordable as is
uh yeah I agree that's true and the
average cost of a heat pump is actually
closer to 13 000 pound and the
government's subsidizing that with 5000
at the moment which taxpayers are paying
for and the issue really is is that we
need lots of different Technologies uh
to heat homes and not just heat pumps
hydrogen District heating schemes
consumes have told us that they want
choice and they want to be able to pick
how they Heat their homes and not be
forced into any single technology so I
think again it's important that we have
those options available and that we work
with consumers to help educate them on
how they hit their homes in the future
great thing about hydrogen which I work
on and and Caden and other other gas
companies is that the boilers in homes
um are going to be the same price as
existing gas boilers so it's no big
change in the in the way you need to
access your heating is very familiar
still it is is a huge project ahead
isn't it I mean how much investment are
you looking to put in to get this going
Investments definitely needed and what
we need the investment in first is
hydrogen production we need investment
in the pipelines that connect those
production centers
um and we're waiting for government to
cement if you like the mechanism that
attracts that investment into the UK
give us a number can you can you give us
an idea of the kind of amount of cash
you're looking at
I I can't right now because it's
integrated into the electricity and
gases integrated together and so all
what we do know though is all of the um
routes if you like to get to netzera are
going to cost uh cost money
um we're going to have to work out as a
country how we protect those that are
most vulnerable
um whether it's electricity or gas or
combinations of the both making sure
we've got resilience infrastructure in
the future that relies on I mean
yesterday is a good example we rely on
it to generate electricity we need to
make sure we have got a resilient energy
infrastructure in the future
unfortunately that is going to come at a
cost
okay we'll leave it there thank you so
much for joining us this morning Angela
needle joining us there
now the president of the European
Central Bank has warned that it intends
to raise interest rates to break through
persistent inflation Christine Lagarde
was speaking at the ECB Forum on Central
Banking which is currently taking place
in sintra in Portugal while joining us
now from sintra is Annette weisbach from
our sister station CNBC with her is the
ground as to what's going on there I
think there's a whole host of central
Bankers there isn't there including um
Jerome Powell from the FED in the United
States we know that Europe has an
inflation problem it's not as bad as for
as here in the UK but interest rates
look set to rise what are you hearing
yes that's exactly the case I think the
general consensusian sinfra which is
like the who's who Gathering of the
world Central Banker is that at least
you're for the Euro area the interest
rates still need to have to rise because
of core inflation is still way too high
and they are very much concerned that
with the wage rounds which are Now
setting in that you get so-called
secondary effects that inflation is kind
of entrenched in the system and if that
is happening central banks have to even
get Bolder and Hike even further to get
inflation out of the system that kind of
like Compares a bit to the 80s
um back in in Germany but also in other
countries in the Euro area where
inflation was super high because of the
energy crisis back in the late 70s early
80s and then central banks hiked their
interest rate up to almost eight percent
I don't want to say this is comparable
but if feels a bit like that so this is
the the so-called hawkish Camp who wants
to have higher interest rates to kill
yeah get rid of inflation and of course
as ever in the Euro area you also have
others other voices such as the
Portuguese Central Banker who is calling
for more moderation because clearly they
are concerned that this abrupt price and
interest rates will in the end dampen
economic growth substantially so that's
the picture here but I think for the
markets it's it's really important to
understand that the ECB is committed to
keep rates high at an elevated very high
level for a longer period of time and
not like the market is currently
thinking that they are going to cut
rates sooner because of that economic
recession which is looming also in Euro
area
okay thank you so much for joining us
live from Portugal there on the latest
on ECB let's bring us a bit of breaking
news as we head to our break we know
that Jeremy Hunt the chancellor is
meeting many of the consumer Watchdogs
including off gem today while off gem
bringing out some breaking news as well
apparently they're going to investigate
British Telecom BT over 999 calls
disruption they're just they're calling
it an own initiative investigation into
BT's compliance uh following BT's
notification of a technical fault which
resulted in A uk-wide disruption to
emergency call services on the 25th of
June 2023
um they go on to say that it requires
certain communication providers to take
all necessary measures to ensure the
fullest possible availability of 999
calls and now that they are going to
launch this own initiative investigation
into what seems to be a breakdown in the
999 core service on the 25th of June uh
in 2023 so what was that just a few days
ago we're bringing more on that when we
have it in the meantime still to come
this morning here on Ian King live we're
going to take a look at how Global
markets are starting the morning and
give you more on the currencies as well
do stay tuned
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
unlock the calendar and I'm Sky's U.S
correspondent based here in Los Angeles
are you still the king maker of this
Republican Party
I've interviewed some of America's most
recognizable politicians and celebrities
too
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
hello there welcome back you're watching
Ian King live with me Emma Crosby now
every year across Europe tens of
thousands of people are killed in road
traffic accidents now the European Union
has set a Target to half the number of
deaths and serious injuries on the roads
by the end of the decade artificial
intelligence could play a key role with
the rise of driver monitoring systems
the Australian company seeing machines
has announced a partnership with the
Swedish startup devant to improve
Vehicle Safety well with me now is the
chief executive and the co-founder of
Devonte Richard Bremer good to have you
on the program I hope I'm pronouncing on
your company correctly
um so the EU has a very ambitious Target
then to cut down on the number of Road
fatalities and injuries and is it
possible to achieve that Target do you
think with new technology
I definitely think that new technology
will play a significant role in
achieving that vision and in Cabin
monitoring systems with the help of
synthetic data and data in general will
play a very important role
so why are driverless cars the answer
then to fewer Road accidents
so I believe that the combination of
autonomous cars and in Cabin monitoring
systems in interaction will will make
sure that the driver can can operate the
vehicle in a more safe manner I think
the the interaction between in-cab and
monitoring systems and exterior sensing
is is a really important and the key to
make sure that we would get a safer
transportation
okay now Richard you're in the business
of human-centric synthetic data so
without going over our heads too much
what is that can you explain it in
layman's terms
so synthetic data is computer generated
data and compared to collecting real
data it takes less time and is less
costly and as with all
um systems that rely on artificial
intelligence you need to get access to a
tremendous amount of high quality data
to make sure that you can get the
performance that you're looking for and
that is of course even more important in
life critical systems like an in-cabin
monitoring system
now there's a forecast that there's
going to be 62 million driverless cars
by the year 2030 which is double the
number that are currently exist put that
into context for us if you can that
number versus driver-led cars is this a
small proportion or is that then going
to become quite large
well again I think that when it comes to
to the combination of the two systems
that that's what what really will make
the difference in the end and the EU has
mandated that all new cars in the
European Union will have in Cabin
monitoring systems installed in a few
years as a standard safety feature and
that is to detect hazardous driver
Behavior like yeah drowsiness and
distraction so in terms of reducing
total number of accidents what we focus
on is familiar in Cabin monitoring side
is there an issue with price point will
these cars be more expensive
so um of course the technology will
develop and we will have new features
but uh it's hard to say how how the
processing point will develop when it
comes to autonomous course but for for
us in close collaboration with uh being
having a monitoring leader seeing
machines we see that
we will make sure that the system is as
good as possible to prevent accidents
a consumer appetite Richard do you think
people are ready for driverless cars
so the thing with an autonomous course
is that they are not ready yet they are
not there yet when it comes to reaching
full autonomy
so
um I think that that that's that's
really one of the key things here that
we need to take a cautious approach not
only to reaching full autonomy but also
to make sure that we step by step add
more safety features to the cabin
monitoring systems
okay we'll leave it there Richard
Bremner the chief executive and
co-founder of Devonte thanks so much for
your time this morning here on Ian King
live thank you let's just pause our
business covers to bring you some
breaking news here on Sky News regarding
Daniel corski he of course is the
conservative at London mayoral candidate
who has had an allegation of groping
leveled against him well a campaign
spokesman person has just said in the
last possible minutes in the strongest
possible terms Dan categorically denies
any allegation of inappropriate behavior
whatsoever the uh the spokesperson as
goes on to say he welcomes any
investigation and he will cooperate
fully we'll bring you more on that when
we have it
foreign
[Music]
with the markets the stock markets
around the world give you the update on
where they are this is the picture for
you in Asia the Nick and I closing up
the day up two percent there at 33.193
in the Shanghai composite having a
pretty flat day closing out at 31.89
Hang Seng ending the day just up one
tenth of a percent in Europe the
Market's well and truly underway
starting out with the Paris and the gem
Market the Dax 40 trading hire ever so
slightly by seven ten to one percent
similar picture in Paris also to in uh
Spain with the mid 30 up three tenths of
one percent sorry that's the uh that's
the Italian one isn't it the Ibex 35 is
up five tenths one percent the Italian
with 30 up three tenths of one percent
the Ft 200 also trading higher at this
hour on there you go up five tenths or
one percent onto the currencies for you
now let's find out how the pound is
faring against the dollar it's falling
against a dollar at this a it's stayed
down three tenths of one percent also
looking weaker again the Euro and the
Euro against the US dollar is pretty
much flat on to the oil Market find out
how much a barrel a Brent crude will
cost you again it's pretty flat at this
hour it'll cost you 72.26
let's try and make sense of those
numbers in a bit more detail with me now
is Victoria scholar head of Investments
at interactive investor joining us now
good to see you Victoria let's talk
about the markets in a few minutes time
there's some company news that's caught
your attention we always like to talk
about when CEOs leave and join new
companies and I know that Revolution
Beauty has got a new CEO tell us more
uh well it's the same CEO that's been
reappointed to the board Revolution
Beauty shares have surged by over 50
today now that it's reinstated enough
directors and it comes after the
appointment the reappointment should I
say of the CEO CFO and the chairman as
well this is uh despite opposition from
shareholders including boohoo which has
a 26.6 in the state in the business and
so tensions are running pretty high
between revolution Beauty and boohoo
which have different views on how to
deal with the low-cost Beauty Brands
problems so there's a lot of uncertainty
ahead uh boohoo has described
revolutions reappointments to the
borders cynical and short-sighted and
misguided but it comes after a pretty
tough time of the business it was forced
to stop trading last September after
video it's accountants pointed to a
potential irregularity in the numbers so
it hasn't been trading since then uh
boohoo wanted to appoint its own choice
of directors to the board Revolution
Beauty has gone against that shareholder
vote and appointed back its own choice
but we have seen that the shares have
absolutely surged today now that they're
back trading on the aim Market but to
put it into context they're still
sharply lower than where they were when
they ipo'd or floated on the stock
market back in the summer of 2021. okay
good one to watch we we know that
corporates usually really like celebrity
tie-ups they're usually good for
business it doesn't seem that's the case
for Diageo right now
no that's right it's ended its business
relationship with Sean Coombs or P Diddy
after the rapper said that the drinks
giant had been neglecting his tequila
brand and actually uh raised claims of
racial discrimination but Diageo has
responded by saying that these are false
and Reckless allegations and even said
they are defamatory around the part
about racism uh so what we know so far
is that coombsa's legal team have filed
a suit last month suggesting that diagio
wasn't actually allocating enough
resources to his Brands compared to
other celebrities so the two sides now
very much at loggerheads and could see
themselves facing a lengthy legal battle
ahead as diagio looks to try to
advertise with de Leon its joint venture
with the rapper but you know it's been a
long-standing partnership diagio has
worked with Coombs since 2007 when it
helped to promote his well-known vodka
brand Ciroc
and the result of that stuff in the
luxury fashion brand Mulberry Victoria
and weaker profits how the shares doing
well we're actually seeing shares
trading pretty well which is surprising
on first glance given that it's a full
year underlying free tax profit came in
Far short of last year 2.5 million this
year versus nearly 15 million a year ago
but investors are encouraged by its
Revenue which is up by four percent and
it's group sales in the first 12 weeks
of this year look ahead of forecasts up
by about six percent and there was
particular strength in Asia Pacific
partly thanks to its new stores in
Australia so it feels as though
investors are shrugging off this bottom
line uh weakness because of its strong
investment in the business which may be
weighing on its profitability for now
but arguably could result in a stronger
performance down the line okay Victoria
thank you so much we'll leave it there
still to come this morning here on Ian
King live the economics of war and new
reports on what violence such as the war
in Ukraine is costing the global economy
to stay tuned
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
hi there welcome back the war in Ukraine
has cost the country's economy 63 of its
GDP well that's according to research by
The Institute for economics and peace
its annual Global Peace Index estimates
that the global economic impact of
violence around the world increased by
17 last year to 17.5 trillion dollars or
13 of global GDP while Steve Kill La is
the founder and executive chairman of
the institute for economics and peace
and as you can see he joins me now in
the studio welcome it's lovely to have
you on the program I mean 17.5 trillion
dollars it's a grim number isn't it and
it's pretty Grim data oh it's it really
really really high and we can see it's
getting worse each year more recently
but I don't think any of us could ever
imagine a world which is a hundred
percent peaceful but what we could do is
imagine a world let's say 10 more
peaceful so it'll be 1.7 trillion
dollars that'll be the equivalent of
adding 3 three new economies to the
world the size of Ireland Switzerland
and Denmark but to put it another way
one percent the cost of violence the
global equipment economy is the
equivalent of all all overseas
developmental Aid last year just one
percent let's talk about Ukraine because
I know that that takes a big chunk of
the number that you've come to
um how much work is going to be involved
getting its economy back up and running
once the violence has stopped well it's
hard to actually see at the moment and
as you mentioned 63 percent of the GDP
has been lost but what you've got to
think about is the infrastructure which
is destroyed as well and a lot of it's
not in that number so it's the sewage
systems it's the water systems and so
quite often really to rebuild all the
infrastructure can again can take 30 to
40 years and a substantial amount of
money so the actual cost was so fast
449 billion dollars and of course human
costs are far outweigh is an economic
cost but I read that 65 of men in
Ukraine aged between 20 and 24 have gone
they've either sadly died or they fled
the country I mean you've also just lost
a huge chunk of of the population the
demographic there yes no that's right so
most of them aren't dead most of them
have left the country in fact you've got
more females have left the country than
males but we focused on the males
because that's the fighting population
so 25 to 28 year olds you've got 54 of
them have left so I think the question
for the Ukraine moving forward is will
they have enough troops to sustain a
long-term campaign and also if they come
back post poster the war being over
let's have a look at some of the others
that or the numbers that you've been
kind of playing around with you've been
looking at tensions as we know in the
south sea between China and the Strait
of Taiwan if things become more hostile
then what is the economic impact for the
rest of us do you say yeah well we did a
study on that what we did is we we
looked at the military blockline of
Taiwan which was only 40 percent
successful not 100 only 40 successful
that it costs 2.7 trillion dollars to
the global economy about three percent
now to be twice the impact of the global
financial crisis but I think the most
surprising thing was when we looked at
the five major trading partners with the
China they turned out to be all advanced
democracies and all militarily
interlinked so that Japan South Korea
Australia Germany in the United States
and so we can see from this currently in
modern Wars it's very very difficult to
win you can see the Russians in
Afghanistan you'd see the Americans
we've seen Iraq we couldn't defeat
Bashir in Syria now we've got the
Ukraine and you can look at Yemen also
so we need to think about new ways of
being able to go about creating peace
because Wars aren't actually winning of
course what has all this done for
defense spending you know how are
governments spending their budgets in
light of what you found well this is the
really interesting fact so what we can
find is overall military spending's up
obviously because the Ukraine war we're
finding military spendings increasing in
Europe but more countries are decreasing
the militarization and increasing well I
think in a lot of other parts of the
world they haven't got the same levels
of conflict they don't see the same need
for the military and it's not that
they're consciously going about reducing
the military they're just adjusting
their budgets to push the money more
towards health education and business
stimulus on a more positive note what
was the most peaceful place to live in
the in the world right now that's
Iceland it has been since we started the
index 17 years ago and a lot of that
comes back to the history of the country
because it's such a hostile environment
people had to pull together and
cooperate Justice about it
thank you very much thank you
[Music]
I come now to have a look at this
morning's business Pages for you here on
ikl let's start with the financial times
reporting that President Putin has
admitted that the Russian State paid
billions of dollars to bankroll the
Wagner paramilitary group also on the
front page as you can see is the story
of the Oda asset management is in talks
to transfer for funds to the investment
Boutique firm SW Mitchell on to the
Times newspaper we know it's business
page leads with Bush's biggest
supermarkets rejecting accusations from
MPS that they are behaving like a cartel
and fueling inflation by profiteering
from soaring free prices also reporting
that the BT's chief executive Philip
Janssen has been reprimanded for saying
that the group's open reach Network
expansion will end in tears for its
Rivals and having a look as well at the
telegraph this morning its business page
leads with a surprise departure of the
boss of Thames water of course we're
importing that heavily here on Skynet as
well Sarah Bentley the company is now
scrambling to raise a billion pounds the
newspaper says from its shareholders and
of course when we get more details on
what's happening with Thames water or
bring them to you live here on Sky News
so to all our next guests as well Simon
English I bet he's got a good idea of
what's going on the financial editor at
the evening standard he is going to talk
to us now uh and uh Simon lots and lots
to unpick in the papers today I know
that you want to start with uh Jeremy
Hunt grilling Regulators on how to
reduce pressure on consumers there you
are you've appeared at last
um we know that meeting is taking place
right now I mean realistically what can
he do does he have any kind of influence
or or power to to tell can tell tell
these big Watchdogs what they can and
can't do
I think he's quite limited actually
um uh he can he can put pressure on them
for sure but then they actually have to
have evidence of something past price
gouging in this case before they can
really uh go any further so the way this
looks to me at the moment
um is the the government has has had
this target that he keeps going on about
how it's going to halve inflation
truthfully there's only so much the
government can do about inflation so
it's trying to look like it's doing
something so it's having these meetings
and it looks like it's holding big
bosses to
um account but it looks like it looks to
me it's more uh PR than anything when it
when it comes to Regulators food is the
biggest concern I think that's
everyone's biggest concern but um all
one of the studies show every time that
it's been investigated Supermarket
profit margins are low and it was
happening really it is a competitive
um functioning Market certainly when it
comes to food
um petrol might be a bit different that
might be a bit more interesting they
could do something bad I think okay
let's get your thoughts on Thames water
big story of course one of our lead
stories this morning
um the government coming out reassuring
or setting off what coming out and
reassuring that the financial well-being
of the major water companies is okay in
this country but nevertheless though the
times leading with a story that water
bills are to rise up to 40 percent to
fix sewage pollution crisis I mean this
is going to make people very angry isn't
it
I would have thought that the reaction
nearly ever be to reading that is just
anger isn't it you know they're going to
charge us more to solve a problem that
is largely of their own making I think
um a Defenders of uh uh the
privatization of those utilities if
there are any left uh what they would
say is well we needed these investors to
come in
um uh to fix the the network and in
return about what we're going to have to
get some amounts of dividend otherwise
why would they invest what's been clear
you know 30 years on from those
privatizations is that the investors
just took out lots of money early on and
the fixing that they were supposed to do
with the of the networks and Water Works
in particular
um well it just never happened so I mean
it seems to me that the the uh that's
increasingly going to be a case for a
call for at least nationalization of
some of those assets and just to go back
to the the headline figure the 40
increase in water bills I actually think
that's a bit of a PR game too I suspect
that comes from that figure has been put
out there by the water companies now
they're going to discussions with the
government on that basis and then it
comes out the prices only go up 20 and
they the government and the water
companies try and uh uh present that as
if it's a result from the basis that
could have been much worse and I think
that that actually won't happen now
you've already can see this pretends I
suspect uh is that some of the water
companies will be um uh re-nationalized
and um at this point it starts right
you're against that why shouldn't we try
that it's a professor situations a
channel
okay we'll leave it there Simon thank
you so I'm in English the financial
editor at the evening standard joining
us there
now as economies continue their drive
towards net zero there has been growth
in the use of voluntary carbon markets
now these allow carbon emitters to
offset their emissions by purchasing
carbon credits which go towards projects
which remove carbon from the atmosphere
now there has been debate about The
credibility credibility I should say of
voluntary carbon markets well today the
voluntary carbon markets Integrity
initiative has published a claims code
of practice and we're going to learn a
bit more about that now because we've
been able to discuss this is Mark Kemba
he is the executive director of the
voluntary carbon markets Integrity
initiative that is quite a mouthful
isn't it how you manage to get through
the day saying that all the time
um let's just go back a little bit and
many of us are not familiar with the
concept of carbon markets still we're
getting used to it of course as we talk
more and more about net zero one of the
shortcomings then the current
shortcomings with carbon markets
um I think it's first just worth
distinguishing between two types of
carbon Market there is the one that many
business businesses in Britain and
Europe will know about which is like the
European or British emissions trading
scheme where governments set a total
limit on the number of emissions that
companies can and have and then
companies can trade amongst themselves
to meet that Target what we're talking
about here is a different thing where
companies or individuals can invest in
projects often in poor countries could
be to protect forests it could be to ref
restore Forest it could be an Energy
Efficiency and then take credit for
those Investments and use them towards
their targets and this is what we mean
by voluntary carbon markets and when you
talk about offsetting of you'll have
often been asked for example when you're
on a flight if you want to offset your
emissions we're not talking so much
about that but the things that companies
do as part of their broader strategies
and the problem is as a consumer or an
investor I don't really know if that
company is really building or planting
lots of trees in the Amazon or doing
something that we have to take their
word for it so in your many years of
working in this space do you see
greenwashing is this why you have to
bring in this code of conduct today
that's certainly a challenge and we've
seen litigation we've seen expose in the
press and that's exactly why we've
published the claims code today because
we want to provide confidence to those
companies that really are doing the
right thing and to their stakeholders
the general public people who are buying
their products but also a way of
distinguishing those who are doing the
right thing from those who aren't and
that's what the claims code will do it's
built with inputs from businesses from
governments from ngos from the general
public and we're pretty confident that
what we've got is something that is a
clear who's going to sign up
uh all sorts of companies have shown
interest we published a provisional
version last year 70 companies Road
tested it they're interested in using
this because they're under pressure from
their investors from public from
consumers and they see this as a
marketing opportunity as well 70s is a
start but it's not a huge number isn't
it what is your ambition for every
every company in the world to be signed
up every major company particularly
those who are engaging with the public
to sign up there will be those who
actually really should just be focusing
much more on reducing their own
emissions and what we are very clear in
the code is using carbon credits or
offsets is not a substitute that's what
you do once you've reduced your own
emissions and that's where you go above
and beyond and that's one of the
questions that people have asked about
green washing are people using something
to cheat no our claims code says you do
that your own work first and then you go
above and beyond I mean and you're
clearly passionate about this there's a
lot of good will behind you I'm sure but
that the issues are it's a non-regulated
market and it's voluntary isn't it I
mean surely something with more teeth is
needed for example in you know companies
need to have legally binded audited
reports at the end of the year is this
not what's needed in in your space as
well absolutely and very we're very
clear about that the volume happening
where are you on that Journey it's
happening but it's not happening quickly
enough I mean some countries have very
good policies in place and some have
very little the voluntary climate action
by companies and voluntary carbon Market
as part of that is filling a gap it's
filling a policy Gap because we haven't
done what we need to in terms of getting
policies in place so we see this as a
short-term opportunity because we need
every tool we've got we need policy but
while it's while that's not enough we
need to invest in Saving the forests and
we see every year just that this week
the report saying the size of
Switzerland has been deforested we need
to invest in protecting those forests we
need to protect in protecting our
agricultural land so where's the drag is
it governments I mean where where is the
lag at the moment well on policy see
it's a combination of governments it's
lobbying it's General inertia but we're
seeing that companies many companies are
going Beyond governments and actually
demanding action themselves and want
Clarity on how they should act and those
who are doing the right thing not being
criticized for it being as I said before
being able to distinguish those who are
from those who aren't doing the right
thing and we could get your views mark
on on the UK's climate change committee
progress report released today I don't
know if you've heard a chance to look at
it I'm not going to grill you on it but
but the the headline is that the UK is
likely to miss it's 20 30 targets
because there is inaction on a policy
front what are your thoughts on that
well I think it's a terrible shame not
only for the climate and as a as a G7
country we should be leading the way we
have the responsibility but also the
opportunity it's also a shame for the
country because we've seen that a lot of
the investment in the green economy
creates jobs creates better revenues
more productivity so we're not just
missing a climate trip we're missing an
economic social trick as well and just
briefly is the UK set to kind of forfeit
or lose the leadership it got from from
hosting cop in Glasgow two years ago
well that was certainly one of the
messages that seems to have been coming
out this morning I hope not we haven't
lost it but we've run the risk of doing
so Mark I didn't talk to you this
morning Mark Campbell he's actually
director of the voluntary carbon markets
Integrity initiative thank you
still to come this morning here on Ian
King live the very first Vet Clinic
offering a subscription-based service
I'll be speaking to its founder after
this short break it's not here my
promise
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
ER and I'm Sky's U.S correspondent based
here in Los Angeles are you still the
king maker of this Republican Party
I've interviewed some of America's most
recognizable politicians and celebrities
too
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Fly Emirates fly better
owners in the UK spent a whopping 4.7
billion pounds on vets and other
services for their animals that's
according to figures from the office for
National statistics the veterinary
Market has been dominated by big
companies including CBS medivet and Vets
for Pets but earlier this year snoots
opened its first clinic in North London
backed by an initial one million pound
investment to offer a subscription based
service well with me now is the founder
of snoots Jonathan moyale good to have
you on the program we're hoping for your
furry friend to come too but uh but
maybe another time
um so 4.7 billion pounds spent on the uh
on pets in what's the cost of living
crisis as we well know in this country
so put that number into context for US
versus other domestic spend that we're
seeing just how big is it it's it's it's
big but it's also it's painful um and I
think it should be bigger is really the
the thing that we're trying to do here
is that people are putting off vet
visits because they're too expensive and
and we we did a survey and it seems like
it's somewhere between 65 and 85 percent
of people have not gone to the vet when
they needed to because they were afraid
of the vet bill and when that happens
Little Things become big things become
bigger things
um and and you know in a cost of living
crisis even not in a cost of living
crisis a vet bill can really quickly be
250 300 pounds a thousand pounds and
insurance isn't covering most of that so
yes it's a it's a very big number uh we
think that still the the market is sort
of underserved in terms of number of vet
touches per year so a subscription-based
Services is your differentiator
something that is new is it in this
country are you a first it's I think
we're new in the world
um so I am American I think everybody
could pick up on that but uh this isn't
something I copied from the us to bring
here uh it's completely new it we're 33
pounds a month and it includes
everything that we do in our clinics so
we only do primary care we don't do
surgery but uh everything from
vaccinations to travel certificates
x-rays blood work things like that sort
of the everyday care that you need for
your pet
um and it we're trying to keep it as
affordable as possible and as accessible
as possible because what we want is for
people to be able to come to the vet
more often as often as possible really
but the big bills are usually surgeries
so if you're not covering that how
useful is it so it's really useful
because a lot of surgery is caused
because we didn't catch things Upstream
um and and as pets kind of age you know
we want to have more touches on an
annual basis even when they're young
a small tiny bump could be a tumor it
could be nothing but when it's a small
tiny bump you can still get rid of it
you can excise it if you wait six months
you might just be going straight to
euthanasia which is heartbreaking I
worked and worked in the pet space for a
long time and and when I wasn't in the
insurance space we we had so many cases
that went to euthanasia either Financial
or regular and that shouldn't have that
never should have and that's that's
really the sort of motivation that
launched me into this specific business
because at the end of the day I'm here
for the pets and talking about what
you're doing in the states we would just
say we're just talking about uh your
previous uh time at bark you IPO that
for 1.5 billion so you've got good uh
pedigree or Heritage never heard that
one
but anyway um but so you you I'm sure
you're going to do very well yeah but
you've got a one billion uh
investment funds and it's not a huge
amount of cash is it so what we've done
is we've opened our first clinic and as
LinkedIn uh so just down the road from
here and um we're hoping to be able to
open the first three this year with with
that investment and then we'll see where
we go from there I think for us the the
goal is to make this as widespread as
possible because you know accessibility
is a problem here in London but it's
also a problem in the north and in the
South and everywhere else and it's quite
a fractured Market I know that there's a
big chunk of the market is is made by
independent vets are you trying to get
them on board I mean what's your
expansion plan so we're working kind of
in conjunction with the Vets because we
don't do surgery right and and the vet
industry structurally has uh focused on
these high margin surgeries and it's
what they want to do we're very bad as
an industry at doing primary care
because it's it's not where the money is
and with corporates coming in it's not
where people are focusing so we're
trying to do one thing that we're only
going to do that we're going to do it
really well and hopefully work with the
other players and when you have to be
profitable
on the clinic basis uh probably in the
fall so the clinics will be profitable
pretty fast as a business we are a
venture-backed startup so profitability
is a bad word for mine do you have an
exit plan I know you've asked that all
the time but it what is the Big Goal is
it to be sold well it's not to be IPO
yeah the big goal for me is I've been in
tech for a long time this is the first
company that I want to run for the next
30 Years
um I really really care about the
patients and and what we're doing and
I'm doing it for the pets so if I can
keep running this thing if I can make it
as big as possible if if it can become
the standard for the industry that
that's the only goal for them and a
quick shout out to your pet at home who
is it alpino Pinos you might have seen
them in the videos he's the poodle he he
actually had a procedure on Monday so
he's he's not doing great no he's not
doing well
thank you so much for joining us
Jonathan Moi alvare the founder of
snoots on what's a subscription-based
vets business
well that is it from me for today I'll
be back on Friday Ian is back tomorrow
plenty more for you on the Sky News
Mobile app and also on the website with
reporting video content and Analysis
from our business team inking back with
you at 10 o'clock up next we have Jane's
second in Westminster ahead of today's
prime minister's questions she'll see in
a moment
foreign